bientôt nous excuser olodio se
retrouvent pour jouer à plusieurs petits
yeux gratuit je parle plus en plus vite
c'est horrible on commence tout de suite
avec gorrias bellator le jeu qui à
l'écran d'accueil le plus travaillé au
mont blanc parti à on a bien cru j'amène
le voir ses goûts rien ok alors déjà
pourquoi ça explose déjà on se calme
dirai comment ça monsieur gorilles et à
ta mission c'est d'aller dans la ville
et de tuer tous les humains que tu vois
et je peux pas tuer mes frères les
gorilles
ok je jette des tonneaux explosifs et je
peux mais c'est ça la maturité a tant
attendu se passer quoi lasser des modes
serpillière quoi c'est hyper chiant mais
où sont donc cacher les humains alors
les tu commences à te lotus ça et ça
fait des conneries [ __ ] ou au lac et
hc lolita techniques d'après arrêté à
saint pierre
ils se doutent de rien de rien mais il
tombait rail tendance à tout va t il
chercher c'est scandaleux
gala bien la nature
ouais on tue tous les mais [ __ ]
parlement volée lobée c'est ça ma toile
à lacets comme s'ils avaient lâché une
bombe sur la ville normande le staff
quoi ton et ses ados sexuelle a sorti
son smartphone quoi oui je suis l'une
des rares personnes en france à dire
smartphone n'est pas portable on n'est
pas du tout dans l'excès pas papa et de
la fumée ça pas en boîte de nuit
bon bah écoutez c'est très éducatif
on est maintenant sur piste simulate on
reste dans la maturité j'ai aucune idée
de aulas c'est très glauque déjà c'est
ça et donc on fait pipi et donc juste à
attendre que les boulettes dans la
cuvette
c'est ça waouh quel jeu passionnant non
mais c'est serré mais c'est chiant mais
y'a pas de plaisir manas louée à ce jeu
à la fin je dois doser la la force déjà
rapproche pas l'urinoir dans un premier
temps ça va peut-être td peut quand même
changé l'attend c'est quoi ça c'est nous
attendait ce gros truc euros-
dégueulasse on dirait un [ __ ] de
cochon qui lancent des ménages par là la
verge l'a vraiment j'ai envie d'appeler
sos développeur chez nous quoi on a fait
des jeux blizzard mais là on atteint le
summum combien regarde cela avec sa tête
tant qu'image c'est ultra glauque on
attaque ce jeu je ne veux plus top
qu'est ce que c'est que ces jeux
aujourd'hui la qui les a choisis encore
ok mais bon cette fois risquent de
s'amuser on est sûr girafe s'aiment pas
et qui aime les ballons va contrôler du
raf à la manière de copains allaient
trouver le butin
elle aime les ballons et devenez ballon
ouais les contrôles attend aulas je
comprends rien aux [ __ ] métier spacex
coup
[Musique]
le cas chez eux c'est le poids celle va
péter un câble c'est ouais bah non
excusez-moi à bas le voilà en fait avec
les touches zqsd ou contrôler son coup
et touche du bas c'est son corps et là
il ya une mine comment sont pas comme ça
commence au tabac voilà non bah voilà
bah allez à temps quel est le délire
excusez moi mais quel est le délire je
pars en explorateur voilà le coup vers
le bas à bas taux aux crs d'ios sans
déconner quoi
hop là ok elle dit exactement la même
on est bien là on est bien on est bien
on est bien voilà on se fraie un chemin
digne des plus grands chemins terre
c'est comme quand on était petit là dans
l'espèce de tous qu'il ya plein de
boules moi je fais ça avec mon cou voilà
je n'ai pas de chute à cette blague
au final il ya presque un an presque
c'est génial ce que j'espère qu'à des
niveaux de manière illimitée et une mine
juste en bas et crois que je n'ai pas vu
je les ai vus bas mais je l'avais vu ses
comptes pas au blanc seau de tout
armement attend elle a fait pape dans la
queue c'est bof ça s'était très bof non
mais va pas vers la vie non mais
pourquoi mes blagues atom et aux pierres
est ce qu'on peut pas aller ça soit on
va te faut juste aller par le haut je me
suis sauvé aux césar fait les avides on
y va comme ça oh non c'est quoi ça what
ouais vas te prends la mine allait
bientôt et pêche toi c'est mme pagé
raffy revient il revient merci bat loeb
merci aux compagnons jusqu'à vrai cette
mine prônons le y avait un petit
moustique à ben voilà le ce qui les ont
battus ce qui met sur les jeux nul quoi
c'est ça qu'est bon allez dégagez les
caisses à l'aller ans arrêté en faire
des kasmas
ouais ouais pas la mine ouais ouais as
tu es un trou très bien et à mon avis on
va sceller notre pote salut voila
non mais attendez arrêt checa bien mon
grand corps de girafes mais tout de même
non non c'est bon via la tête qui
retient dans l'âme a pas autant jeter
pays d'activer le nom clip mode la up
non non je refuse est moi [ __ ] mais
c'est vraiment la foire et cette petite
boule là ok bien on s'est tu sur lui oh
oui oh là là on peut lui dire merci je
ne peux pas je ne vois pas merci dont il
met n'est pas trop grave
non je déteste ça c'est le mouv style et
voilà on apprécie ce moment à chaque
fois c'est bien le seul moment qu'on
apprécie dans ses débuts au allez on y
va on y va ballon olala du bout du bout
de la corde
alors là qu'est ce qu'ils savaient de
quoi le piège il en explorateur
j'aimerais bien souhaiter bon niveau
mais c'est impossible par la diva comme
ça nickel cb quoi en fait oui c'est
pareil au nom dans la gauche est plus
simple aux os us qu'il alors là c'est
quoi ce bordel ya pas de mise encore
arrêtée avec les mines bordel je sais
pas comment il a fait juste avant pour
passer mais c'est est ce qu'il est ok on
arrive en bas
oh là là on a fini au jura 100 vaches
fini les gorets il est gérable même
attention alcoolique simulator parce que
l'alcool c'est mieux ça faut que j'en
retire montage où il ferait penser
c'est donc sur les simulateurs j'ai
aucune foutue idée de comment jouer à ok
c'est un peu comme si simulator ou les
trucs comme ça mais version aucun budget
les versions note marcel planche de bois
quoi bière et ensuite on la voit comme
ange pas comme ça sera comme ça devrait
on pas comme ça vous la lancez là-bas
dans le dans la corbeille non non ah non
[ __ ] ya un verre j'avais pas vu web et
vas-y doit pas les infos oh oui et alors
ensuite elle est profondément ont fait
reculer indiqué schumi à côté parfait ça
dégage ses bras est tombée elle a voulu
revenir mais non non non dans donc
maintenant mais c'est quoi ça je l'adoré
classe vers sedan mais non et là aussi
je vois comment comment je la crois mais
rodez vient là oh oui j'adore je t'adore
vraiment vu la gueule de la main de cet
homme c'est le pinocchio qui se mène
gueule de bois si j'ai bien compris ça
va rebooster là pour réussir ce [ __ ]
de jeu allait beau jeu de mots on adore
ça ok apparemment il faut mettre sa main
tout en haut pour moi ah bah voilà c'est
passionnant j'adore vraiment pas en
dépendent virtuel vive internet en 2015
c'est passionnant je pratique le karaté
de père en fils et je me cache le visage
et on termine la vidéo sur sa salut toi
je suis ton petit doigt je t'aime fort
cette vidéo commence à devenir bizarre
et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo sur ses quatre petits jeux
gratuits j'espère ça vous a plu si ces
caméscopes au mieux le vide et aux
plaisirs des jeux sont la description si
vous voulez jouer à sempai girafe mais
pardon ses attentions cacher les yeux de
vos du raf à bord vers savoir regarder
on s'en doute reviendrons dans une
prochaine vidéo 4
[Musique]